hello my name is Jessa and I'm a member
of a hip-hop collective called Doomtree
I'm the one in the tanktop and I make my
living as a performing de touring rapper
and singer when we perform is a
collective this is what our shows look
like I'm the one in the boots there's a
lot of jumpin there's a lot of sweating
it's loud it's very high-energy
sometimes there are unintentional body
checks on stage sometimes there are
completely intentional body checks on
stage it's kind of a hybrid between an
intramural hockey game and a concert
however when I perform my own music as a
solo artist I tend to gravitate towards
more melancholy sounds a few years ago I
gave my mom the rough mixes of a new
album and she said baby it's beautiful
but why is it always so sad
you always make music to bleed out - I
thought who are you hanging out with it
you know that phrase but over the course
of my career I'd written so many sad
love songs that I got messages like this
from fans release no music or a book I
need help with my breakout and after
performing and recording and touring
those songs for a long time I found
myself in a position in which my
professional niche was essentially
romantic devastation what I hadn't been
public about however was the fact that
most of these songs had been written
about the same guy and for two years we
tried to sort ourselves out and then for
five and on and off for ten and I was
not only heartbroken but I was uh
I was kind of embarrassed that I
couldn't rebound from what other people
seems to recover from so regularly and
even though I knew it wasn't doing
either of us any good I just couldn't
figure out how to put the love down then
drinking my wine one night I saw a TED
talk by a woman named dr. Helen Fisher
and she
said that in her work she'd been able to
map the coordinates of love in the human
brain and I thought well if I could find
my love in my brain maybe I could get it
out so I went to Twitter anybody got
access to an fMRI lab like at midnight
or something I'll trade for backstage
passes and whisky and that's dr. Cheryl
Ullman who works at the University of
Minnesota's Center for magnetic
resonance research she took me up on it
I explained the dr. Fischer's protocol
and we decided to recreate it with a
sample size of one so I got decked out
in a pair of forest green scrubs and I
was laid on a gurney and wheeled into an
fMRI machine if you're unfamiliar with
that technology essentially an fMRI
machine is a big tubular magnet that
tracks the progress of deoxygenated iron
in your blood so it's essentially
figuring out what parts of your brain
are making the biggest metabolic demand
at any given moment and in that way it
can figure out which structures are
associated with the tasks like tapping
your finger for example always light up
the same region or in my case looking at
pictures of your ex-boyfriend and then
looking at pictures of a dude who just
sort of resembled my ex-boyfriend but
for whom I had no strong feelings he was
the control and when I left the machine
we had these really high-resolution
images of my brain we could cleave the
two halves apart we could inflate the
cortex to see inside all of the wrinkles
essentially in a view that dr. Cheryl
Ullman called the brain skin rug and we
could see how my brain had behaved when
I looked at images of both men and this
was important we could track all of the
activity when I looked at the control
and when I looked at my ex and it wasn't
comparing these data sets that would be
able to find the love alone in the same
way that if I were to step on a scale
fully dressed and then step on it again
naked the difference between those
numbers would be the weight of my
clothing so when we did that data
Parris and we subtracted one from the
other we found activity in exactly the
regions that dr. Fisher would have
predicted that's me and that's my brain
in love there was activity in that
little orange dot the ventral tegmental
area that kind of loop of red is the
anterior cingulate and that golden set
of horns is the caudate after she'd had
time to analyze the data with her team
and a couple of partners Andrew Phil
Cheryl sent me an image a single slide
it was my brain in cross-section with
one bright dot of activity that
represented my feelings for this dude
and I know I'd know when I was in love
and that's the whole reason I was going
to these outrageous lengths but having
an image that proved it felt like such a
vindication like yeah it's all in my
head but now I know exactly where and I
also felt like an assassin who had her
mark
that was what I had to annihilate so I
decided to embark on a course of
treatment called neurofeedback
I worked with a woman named penny gene
grace fire and she explained that what
we'd be doing was training my brain
we're not lobotomizing anything we're
training it in the way that we would
train a muscle so that it would be
flexible enough and resilient enough to
respond appropriately to my
circumstances so when were on the
treadmill we would anticipate that our
heart would beat and pound and when
we're asleep we would ask that that
muscle slow
similarly when I'm in a long-term viable
loving romantic relationship the
emotional centers of my brain should
engage and when I'm not in a long-term
viable emotional loving relationship
they should eventually chill out so so
she came over with a set of electrodes
just smaller than a dime that were
sensitive enough to detect my brain
waves through my bone and hair scalp and
when she rigged me up I could see my
brain working in real-time
and in another view that she showed me I
could see exactly which parts of my
brain or hyperactive here displayed in
red hypoactive here displayed in blue
and the healthy thresholds of behavior
the green zone the Goldilocks zone which
is where I wanted to go and we can in
fact isolate just those parts of my
brain that were associated with the
romantic regulation that we'd identified
in the Fischer study so penny gene
several times hooked me up with all her
electrodes and she explained that I
didn't have to do or think anything I
just essentially had to hold pretty
still and stay awake and watch so I did
and every time my brain operated in that
healthy threshold I got a little run of
harp or vibraphone music and I just
watched my brain rotated roughly the
speed of in your own machine on my dad's
flat-screen TV and that was
counterintuitive
she said the learning would be
essentially unconscious but then I
thought about the other things that I
had learned without actively engaging my
conscious mind when you write a bike I
don't really know what like my left calf
muscles doing or or how my latissimus
dorsi knows to engage when I wobble to
the right the body just learns and
similarly like EV loves dogs probably
don't know a lot about like protein
structures or the wave form of a ringing
Bell but they salivate nonetheless
because the body paired the stimuli
finish the sessions went back to dr.
Cheryl almonds fMRI machine and we
repeated the protocol the same images of
the ex of the control and in the
interest of scientific rigor Cheryl and
her team didn't know who was who so that
they couldn't influence the results and
after she had time to analyze that
second set of data she sent me that
image she said dude a dominance of your
brain seems to essentially have been
eradicated I
this is the desired result comma yes
question why and how it was exactly the
desired result and finally I allowed
myself a moment to introspect like how
how did I feel
and in one way it felt like it was the
same inventory of feelings that I'd had
at the outset you know this is an
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
the dude was in a straining but I'd had
love and jealousy and Amity and
attraction and respect and all those
complicated feelings that you amass
after long-term loves but it felt like
the benevolent feelings had risen to the
surface and the feelings of fixation and
the less generous feelings weren't quite
so present and that sounds like a small
thing in some way like this resequencing
of feelings but to me it felt like the
biggest thing like if if I told you I'm
going to anesthetize you and I'm also
going to take out your wisdom teeth it
would really matter to you the sequence
in which I did those two and I also felt
like I'd had this really unusual
philosophical privilege to understand
love the lab offered to 3d prints my
caudate I got to hold love in my hand
and then I bronze did and I made it into
a necklace and sold it at the merch
table at my show
[Applause]
and then with the help of a couple of
friends back in Minneapolis one of them
Becky we made an enormous disco ball
that could descend from the ceiling at
my big shows and I felt like I'd had the
opportunity to better understand love
even even the compulsive parts it isn't
a neat symmetrical Valentine's heart its
bodily it's systemic it is a hideous
pair of rams horns buried somewhere deep
within your skull and when that special
boy walks by it lights up and if he
likes you back and you make each other
happy then you fan the flames and if he
doesn't then you assemble a team of
neuroscientists to snuff him out
[Applause]
[Music]